bonsoir et bienvenue dans savour garde
notre grand témoin ce soir et diplomate
il fut le premier ambassadeur de France
à Kiev après la chute du Mur bonsoir rue
de Pernay bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous étiez au premier loge au moment de
l'implosion de l'Union soviétique au
moment en 1991 au l'Ukraine proclame son
indépendance vous racontez tout cela
dans un livre la guerre en Ukraine était
déjà en germ était déjà écrite nous
dites-vous il y a 30 ans on va en parler
longuement tout à l'heure ensemble mais
on commence bien sûr avec le jour
d'après le 49-3 à l'Assemblée crise
politique le gouvernement peut-il tomber
crise sociale la radicalisation est-elle
en marche crise démocratique le divorce
entre le peuple et ses représentants
est-il consommé trois grandes questions
pour notre grand débat ce soir dans un
instant avec nos invités avant de
retrouver à 20h15 les parties pris de
nos affranchis et le bourbon Express
bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vous me suivez
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
et si c'était le coup de force de trop
au lendemain du 49.3 sur les retraites
Emmanuel Macron apparaît affaibli et
isolé crise sociale crise politique
crise démocratique je le disais les
conséquences sont très lourdes et on va
en parler ce soir avec vous Pascal
Perino bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau bonsoir Catherine tricot plaisir
de vous retrouver directrice des
éditions de la revue regardes Pascal
perrenault vous êtes évidemment
polytologue pardonnez-moi professeur
assurance Po Paris j'ai l'impression que
tous les Français vous connaissent bien
mais je précise quand même bonsoir Elsa
bonagava bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste politique bien sûr à la
rédaction LCP vous suivez depuis des
mois ce feuilleton des retraites et
bonsoir Stéphane zumsteg bienvenue
directeur du département Opinion à
l'institut de sondage
Ipsos Huc Pernay diplomate grand
observateur des politiques ce qui se
passe en France retraité droit de
réserve qui tombe ça tombe bien
n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez alors on va commencer avec la
colère sociale qui gronde dans le pays
la rue chauffait à blanc par le 49.3
avec des rassemblements spontanés un peu
partout en France Stéphane backowski
pour commencer il nous plante le décor
c'est le chrono de la cosse est parti
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir
Myriam salut Elisa bonsoir à toutes et à
tous alors l'ampleur de la grogne après
ce coup de force les conséquences du
49-3 sur le mouvement social on va dire
plus simple c'est peut-être de prendre
l'exemple de ce qui s'est passé hier à
la Concorde au départ au début
d'après-midi voilà c'était un petit
rassemblement réalisé par un seul
syndicat solidaire dont on voit ici les
ballons la place était pas remplie bravo
une grosse pression sur l'assemblée à ce
moment-là ce qui a tout changé en
revanche c'est à partir du moment où le
gouvernement à sortir les 49-3 regardez
on est au même endroit on voit qu'il y a
eu des afflux de full considérables à la
fin de la journée on parlait 10000
personnes selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur et puis troisième étape
celle qu'on pouvait redouter parce que
ça c'est un peu improvisé ce
rassemblement et bien il y a eu des
débordements à Paris dans les rues
alentours 250 interpellations à prix ce
qui est un chiffre vraiment très
important donc ça s'est passé à peu près
sur le même scénario dans toutes les
villes de France donc on va dire pour
résumer d'un côté oui le 49.3 accentué
apparemment la mobilisation et de
l'autre on s'inquiète un peu des
conséquences du durcissement du
mouvement l'Inter de syndical vous
pensez bien connaissez par cœur donc ça
se sentait dans leur prise de parole
hier pas de triomphalisme pas de
déclaration tapageuse uniquement du
calme et de la détermination
l'Inter syndical continu à exiger le
retrait de cette réforme en toute
indépendance dans des actions calmes et
déterminées elle décide de poursuivre la
mobilisation et appelle à des
rassemblements syndicaux de proximité ce
week-end et à une nouvelle grande
journée de grève et de manifestations le
jeudi 23 mars prochain donc grosse
mobilisation jeudi et en attendant dès
ce weekend des rassemblements un peu par
tout en France le problème c'est que
tout le monde n'a pas eu la patience
d'attendre ce week-end par exemple dès
ce matin des actions se sont un peu
improvisées regardez ça c'était sur le
périph nord des militants de la CGT à
Paris qui ont interrompu la circulation
pas très méchant pendant une demi-heure
mais il n'en fallait pas plus pour que
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui était sur
RTL phase preuve de fermeté en l'écoute
n'acceptera pas mis ça à l'intérieur et
ce qui sera critique c'est si ces
manifestations sont spontanées empêchent
les circulations empêche les trains de
rouler empêche l'électricité d'arriver
dans des hôpitaux ou dans des dans des
villes mais oui on ne laissera pas faire
et ce sera peut-être critique pour
reprendre votre mot des manifestations
spontanées et le n'importe quoi à tout
moment donc Gérald Darmanin dramatise le
problème de la terre syndicale c'est que
elle n'est pas forcément jamais à l'abri
de deux trois énervées qui feraient
n'importe quoi deux trois énervés très
fiers d'eux qui en plus se filmerait
diffuserait sur les réseaux sociaux et à
la fin même sur LCP on verrait le
résultat donc c'est à Dijon hier les
individus ontflammé des mannequins avec
des effigies de membres du gouvernement
donc oui c'est consternant un glaçons on
peut comprendre d'ailleurs que Aurore
berger à cette occasion ou peut-être
simplement par rapport au climat et
demander une protection policière pour
les membres de la majorité qui serait
menacés que Jacques Darmanin d'ailleurs
accordé enfin là ça sera un moment
injuste d'accorder autant de place
ces images
déprimantes et consternantes alors que
pendant maintenant deux mois il y a eu
des millions de manifestations calmes et
bien organisées à Paris et comme le
rappelle Fabien Roussel mais personne
absolument personne n'appelle à la
violence
aucun syndicat n'appelle brûler des
poubelles
aucun responsable politique n'appelle à
le faire
c'est pour moi une réaction
spontanée
qui est le fruit d'un pourrissement
provoquer par par le gouvernement par le
Président de la République qui a fait ce
choix donc les conséquences du 49-3 sur
la tension sociale vous allez en parler
qui est évident c'est que berger
Martinez sont plus uniques jamais donc
que la mobilisation va se poursuivre je
pense qu'à un moment ou un autre dans le
débat quelqu'un va parler de la manière
dont le CPE a été retiré en 2006 est-ce
qu'on prend le même chemin le contrat
premier embauche je m'en souviens moi
merci beaucoup merci Stéphane Pascal
perrenault il y a des mouvements
spontanés un peu partout on entend les
manifestants excédés dégoûtés par la
méthode est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que le 49-3 va faire
basculer le mouvement dans la révolte
non je ne crois pas ces mouvements sont
importants mais sont des mouvements qui
restent minoritaires
marqués par des militants des activistes
qui cherchent l'affrontement qui
cherchent la violence il y avait des
manifestants qui disaient mais j'ai
écouté les reportages moi je manifeste
c'est la première fois mais le type même
de l'activisme c'est celui qui
s'introduit dans des manifestations
paisibles comme ça l'était au début
place de la Concorde pour faire
dégénérer le mouvement il a besoin de la
protection des gens qui sont là en effet
sans aucune mauvaise mauvaise intention
cet article 49 alinéa 3 alors on parle
vous parliez tout à l'heure de coup de
force
il est prévu par la Constitution
démocratique ça a été utilisé 100 fois
sur la Cinquième République il y
aurait-il eu donc sans coup de force là
il est dans un cadre particulier dans
une procédure déjà particulière
constitutionnelle 47 ans particulière
l'article 49 alinéa 3 a été utilisée de
la Constitution là il arrive dans déjà
dans une procédure contrainte dans le
temps oui mais ça fait partie tout cela
des armes du parlementarisme rationalisé
ça a été inventé par le général de
Gaulle et la gauche du mollet est
d'accord avec tout cela et la gauche en
1958 pour sortir de la stabilité
gouvernementale de la 4e et du désordre
démocratique de la quatrième comment
vous donc pour vous ça n'est pas une
forme d'échec ce 49-3 pour bien
comprendre c'est autre chose à la faveur
de vos propos autre chose mais arrêtons
avec l'histoire du dédit démocratique il
faudra appeler tous les gens qui parlent
de cela à relire tout simplement la
Constitution la constitution de faut
dire des choses basiques mais c'est
notre loi commune si on remet en cause
la loi commune mais où va-t-on où
va-t-on alors maintenant est-ce que en
effet
c'était ça aurait été préférable
d'ailleurs je crois que le Président de
la République l'a dit ça aurait été
préférable en effet qui a eu un vote en
bonne et due forme mais on sait depuis
besoin 2022 on sait en effet qu'il y a
une majorité relative pour les forces de
la majorité mais qui est faible il leur
manque 40 députés ils avaient passé un
accord mais l'État avec Hélène mais
l'état de LR fait qu'ils sont incapables
de tenir quelques promesses que ce soit
et donc ils se sont aperçus au dernier
moment qu'il y avait trop le député LR
qui allait faire défections on va y
venir moi j'avais envie de commencer par
la crise sociale et ensuite on va venir
la crise politique et pourquoi même
démocratique parce que ça pose une
question quand même quand il n'y a pas
de vote possible alors que la majorité
du pays est contre une référence
absolument on va y venir chapitre par
chapitre 4e tricot sur la crise sociale
les gilets jaunes qui étaient moins
nombreux que les manifestants ont fait
céder le gouvernement comment on résout
cette équation là est-ce que ça veut
dire que cette fois sur les retraites
les manifestants vont passer à la
vitesse supérieure
ils ont fait céder les gouvernements
pour partie seulement c'est à dire
qu'ils ont obtenu une partie de leur
revendication mais une partie qui était
qui portait sur la dimension
démocratique elle n'a pas abouti et par
ailleurs la RIP notamment mais sur la
proposition principale la revendications
oui moi ce que j'ai l'impression qui est
en train de se passer c'est que on le
sait sondage après sondage que les
Français étaient opposés à cette réforme
et que en même temps beaucoup pensaient
qu'elle allait passer c'est-à-dire qu'il
y avait pratiquement 70% qui prend qui
était contre et 70% qui pensaient
qu'elle allait passer ce qui s'est passé
hier soir c'est que à la fois il y a des
gens qui l'ont pris comme étant vraiment
une gifle c'est-à-dire que non seulement
c'était à la faveur d'une réforme de
budget de la réexécurité sociale avec un
temps réduit etc il y a pas eu de vote
sur l'article 7 il y a pas de vote sur
la loi et donc les gens n'ont pas du
tout bien pris mais en même temps cet
aveu de faiblesse cette faiblesse là a
redonné de la force c'est à dire qu'on a
vu des gens qui d'un seul coup ce sont
remis à croire alors qu'on a vu que la
dernière manifestation était un peu en
retrait que les grèves ont eu du mal à
partir c'est pas parce que les gens
n'étaient pas fâchés contre cette
réforme c'est qu'il ne pensait pas
pouvoir gagner et là ce que moi j'ai
comme sentiment c'est qu'il va y avoir
certainement des gens qui vont essayer
de brûler des poubelles ou je sais pas
quand c'est radicalisation massive mais
non je ne crois pas ce qui va être
massif c'est de nouveau la confiance et
l'idée qu'on peut gagner et ça ça peut
de nouveau réélargir le spectre des
manifestants on a parlé de l'opinion à
l'instant Stéphane zoum steak jusqu'à
présent l'opinion a toujours soutenu à
la fois les manifestants et elle a elle
était contre la réforme à chaque fois 60
65 % contre la réforme et pour et pour
au fond le mouvement social est-ce que
ça peut s'étioler dans le temps si les
actions violentes comme on en voit
augmentent probablement pas compte tenu
de ce qui s'est passé de ce 49-3 contenu
de du fait que les oppositions notamment
les organisations syndicales restent
extrêmement mobilisées je ne pense pas
qu'on va vers un essoufflement du
soutien certes il y a eu des journées de
mobilisation il y avait moins de monde
dans les rues mais pour des raisons
évidentes de pouvoir d'achat et de
l'aspect punitif de du fait de se mettre
en grève mais aujourd'hui je pense que
le gouvernement n'en a vraiment pas fini
avec son chemin de croix
l'opinion les Français veulent que le
mouvement se poursuivent après le 49 je
crois que le mouvement se poursuivre
quand on leur demande si le fait de
censurer le gouvernement est une bonne
idée il doit répondre oui bien sûr c'est
une bonne idée pourquoi non pas parce
que l'idée d'une censure en soi est
intéressante mais parce que tout ça
pourrait amener éventuellement dans leur
esprit en tout cas à faire plier le
gouvernement à un moment donné donc
l'opinion est restée vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure très longtemps et
toujours et de façon massive et
remarquablement stable favorable au
mouvement social et ça ne va sans doute
pas s'étirer on a beaucoup dit je pense
à tort ces dernières semaines que des
Français étaient résignés vous citiez le
fait que ils étaient contre mais ils se
disait il faisait le
pronostics parce que vous faites le
pronostic que le gouvernement passera ou
réussira que vous êtes résigné et à
partir du moment où vous voyez que il y
a un certain nombre de mouvements
spontanés comme ceux de hier soir que
Stéphane blackovski évoquait tout à
l'heure que il y a déjà des préavis de
grève pour lundi et mardi dans
l'éducation nationale justement au
moment des épreuves de spécialité du
baccalauréat les Français vont se dire
mais finalement la flamme de la lutte
elle s'entretient c'est pas c'est pas
parce que tout ça en supposant que le
gouvernement ne soit pas censuré
évidemment mais même si le gouvernement
devait s'en sortir parce qu'on
appellerait une victoire et ce qui
évidemment ne serait pas une je pense
que la contestation si elle est bien
entretenue par les organisations
syndicales si les partis politiques des
oppositions donne une meilleure image
que celle qu'ils ont pu donner ces
derniers mois notamment dans l'hémicycle
les Français vont se dire et c'est en ça
que je suis totalement d'accord et ce
que vous dites que finalement même si on
y croyait pas peut-être qu'il est
possible à un moment donné de faire
céder peu importe le résultat mais pour
le gouvernement c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle parce que ça va durer ça va
durer plus longtemps qu'il ne le croyait
Elsa les députés de la majorité on l'a
vu pour être visée quand dans les
prochains jours alors il y a le le
mauvais souvenirs pour les députés de la
majorité c'était la crise des gilets
jaunes ou certains évidemment avaient vu
leur permanence vandalisée il y en a
certains qui avaient même été intimidés
à leur domicile donc on l'a entendu la
patronne du groupe Renaissance a demandé
au ministre de l'Intérieur qui est des
protections en fait aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que ils ont du mal à se
rendre compte effectivement c'était il y
a à peine 24 heures un peu plus de 24
heures ils ont du mal à se rendre compte
qu'elles seront vraiment les effets mais
effectivement ils avaient déjà bien du
mal à la défendre sur le terrain cette
réforme des retraites la justifier cet
article l'utilisation de cet article qui
est certes constitutionnelle mais qui
est vraiment synonyme alors même si vous
l'avez démontré parce qu'elle perdrino
vous avez pas cette analyse mais
synonyme pour les gens de passage en
force c'est bien ce que les Français je
pense ont en tout cas à l'esprit ils ont
du mal à mesurer donc on avait
l'impression chez eux certains disaient
bon ça va être plutôt weekend en famille
un peu tranquille d'autres dizaines non
il faut qu'on aille sur le terrain parce
qu'il faut qu'on sache comment cette
séquence elle a été perçue par les
Français peut-être qu'il y a un peu un
décalage entre la classe politique et
médiatique est-ce que les Français en
pensent vraiment donc ils auront des
retours lundi de la circonscrit l'unité
syndicale est renforcée par ce 49-3 bah
beaucoup parier sur le fait que s'il y
avait un vote on allait voir la CFDT
plus prompte à respecter une légitimité
démocratique et il voyait voilà une
possible scission dans l'instar
syndicale
là le 49-3 fait que pour l'instant ils
sont tous d'accord pour dénoncer cette
méthode du gouvernement et pour
continuer la mobilisation parce qu'elle
pereno avant de parler de la crise
politique elle est je mets un point
d'interrogation je vois votre prudence
mais en tout cas de ce qui va se passer
à l'Assemblée nationale l'émotion de
censure déposée à ce stade du bras de
fer et malgré le 49.3 est-ce que vous
pensez que que la réforme peut encore
être retirée
à la réforme peut toujours être retirée
c'était le cas par exemple pour le CPE
voilà Chirac avait décidé de retirer la
réforme après qu'elle ait été votée vous
pensez qu'on peut arriver à ce contexte
là ou pas on peut arriver tout dépend en
effet de l'évolution du rapport de force
puisque il s'agit de cela et de l'issue
également de la journée de lundi parce
que on dit il n'y a pas de vote si il y
aura un vote c'est pas parce que une
idée fausse est répétée plusieurs fois
qu'elle devient un fait vrai il y aura
bien un alors et on verra pas sur la loi
on va voir justement c'est ça a été
utilisé je le répète 100 fois sous la
Cinquième République et beaucoup plus
par la gauche justement on y vient
l'étape d'après c'est la censure
l'émotion devrait être examinée lundi
dans les mes cycles gouvernement peut-il
tomber c'est une question et les
moindres avec tiboine
hier Elisabeth borne a en tête la
prochaine et dernière étape de la
bataille des retraites au Parlement
dans quelques jours je n'en doute pas à
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement répondront une ou plusieurs
notions de censure un vote aura donc
bien lieu comme il se doit la motion de
censure ou l'ultimarme des oppositions
pour tenter d'empêcher l'adoption de la
réforme des retraites une arme aussitôt
dégainée nous allons déposer une motion
de censure nous voterons l'ensemble des
motions de censure déposées rien n'est
fini nous répondrons évidemment par la
censure deux motions de censuront ainsi
été déposés aujourd'hui la première
émanant du rassemblement national n'a
aucune chance d'être adopté car la
gauche ne la votera pas la seconde en
revanche est plus menaçante pour le
gouvernement initié par le groupe liote
elle pourrait faire l'objet d'un vote
transpartisan nous voulons évidemment
que le plus grand nombre des
parlementaires votent cette notion de
censure pour qu'elle passe nous avons
besoin aussi du soutien des députés LR
un vote des députés les républicains qui
pourraient en effet être déterminant
pour être adopté une motion de censure
doit recueillir la majorité absolue dans
l'hémicycle soit 287 voix avec 149
députés de la nupes 88 du rassemblement
national 20 du groupe Lyot et 5 non
inscrits les opposants à la réforme
peuvent espérer au mieux totaliser 262
voix il en manquerait donc 25 le groupe
les républicains pourraient-ils les
apporter c'est toute la question a
priori la réponse est non nous ne
voulons pas rajouter du chaos au cas où
et c'est pour cela que nous venons de
décider en réunion de groupe que nous
nous associerons à aucune notion de
censure et que nous ne vote rien aucune
motion de censure mais certains députés
à la réforme n'exclut pas de voter une
motion à titre individuel toutes les
hypothèses sont possibles pour chacun
des députés librement parce que nous
sommes des députés libres d'ici la
semaine prochaine si la notion devait
être adoptée le gouvernement serait
renversé si c'est un échec en revanche
la réforme des retraites sera considérée
comme définitivement adopté
et c'est à nouveau les républicains qui
détiennent cette fois les clés de cette
censure elles ont pu croire cette fois
Éric ciotique quand il dit que son
groupe parlera d'une seule voix ou alors
on peut croire que le mot d'ordre en
tout cas d'érection type président du
parti d'Olivier Marleix président du
groupe c'est dire à il ne faut pas voter
de motion de censure on sait que
certains députés ont déjà dit qu'ils la
voteraient mais c'est très marginal et
comme Thibault l'explique dans le sujet
25 ça paraît quand même très très grand
parce que on voyait que la fourchette
haute pour ceux qui voteraient contre la
réforme c'était autour de 22 là une
motion de censure clairement on est
responsable de faire tomber le
gouvernement pas sûr que les
républicains aient envie d'une
dissolution derrière et de retourner en
campagne exactement mais ça peut se
jouer pour le coup à peu de voix près 10
15 20 voix ce qui serait quand même un
avertissement pour le gouvernement même
si a priori la motion ne passerait pas
parce qu'elle perrenault vous pensez que
les Français comprennent ça en gros les
républicains
pour certains n'auraient pas
cette réforme des retraites mais ne
voterons pas la censure alors si vous
voulez d'abord la question n'est pas la
même on ne répond pas de la même manière
à des questions différentes là il s'agit
en effet d'un acte extrêmement grave
mettre à bas le gouvernement c'est
arrivé une seule fois sous la Cinquième
République c'était en 1962 avec le
gouvernement Pompidou depuis ça n'est
jamais arrivé et on ne peut que sans
féliciter c'est comme ça en effet qu'on
a affaire à des gouvernements qui ont de
la durée et qui peuvent mettre en oeuvre
des politiques et qui peuvent contribuer
dans une certaine mesure à réformer le
pays donc ça on ne prouve toutes les
autres oppositions quelles qu'elles
soient sont désirresponsables
aujourd'hui en votant
je constate que s'il y avait une
majorité à mon avis il n'y aura pas de
majorité pour faire tomber le
gouvernement parce que les républicains
sont tout de même porteurs d'une culture
de gouvernement
c'est pas le cas des députés des défis
c'est pas le cas de beaucoup des députés
écologistes et c'est pas le cas des
députés du rassemblement national les
républicains avec leurs défauts et leurs
qualités ils ont tout de même une
culture de gouvernement c'est un
ensemble en particulier
au rassemblement national et le risque
de perdre des sièges et je viens dans la
balance donc à mon avis il n'y aura pas
de mise en cause de la responsabilité
gouvernante et puis la coalition qui
mettrait éventuellement à bas le
gouvernement borne elle est capable de
dire non elle est incapable de dire oui
à quoi que ce soit vous voyez un
gouvernement avec des ministres et les
filles et des ministres eren bon c'est
assez peu probable pour l'instant et les
filles dit nous ne voulons pas des
reines en revanche s'il y a une majorité
contre le gouvernement borne les voies
de et les filles seront mêlées aux voix
du rassemblement national il faut que
tout de même les gens se rendent compte
de ce qui est en train de
une motion transpartisane Catherine
tricot de censure c'est quand même dire
on n'est pas d'accord avec ce
gouvernement et ceux qui tombent je veux
dire quand on est opposant ou alors on
fait partie de la majorité on ne devient
moi je pensais une hypothèse que les LR
aillent au bout de leur logique et
rallye directement la macronie et
pourquoi pas mais si ce n'est pas le cas
je trouve étrange de ne pas voter la
motion de censure sur un moment où il y
a une telle crise politique démocratique
et une défiance dans le pays mais le
deuxième argument c'est que l'idée que
Macron dissout est-ce que Macron il est
sûr qu'il fait plus qu'il sort mieux
qu'il sort renforcés après cette dans le
cas d'une telle façon
d'âge là mais il y a des sondages qui
circulent sur une hypothèse de
dissolution les législatives ça donne
quoi
c'est le gouvernement est toujours en
place mais ceci dit c'est pas pour
autant qu'on peut pas émettre quelques
non pas des pronostics mais en tout cas
de
confrères Henri s'interactif tout le
monde
ce qui s'est passé dernière semaine de
l'opposition de l'hostilité massive des
Françaises projets de la chute
d'Emmanuel Macron et d'Elisabeth borne
dans les enquêtes de popularité comment
imaginer que s'il y avait dissolution
une nouvelle élections législatives le
bloc présidentiel 250 sièges à peu près
pourrait progresser c'est c'est très
très fortement improbable je pense que
on peut raisonnablement supposer que
toutes les oppositions progresseraient
un peu mais que évidemment le bloc
macroniste perdrait quelques dizaines de
quelques dizaines de députés sur
Elizabeth borne que vous mentionnez la
grève n'a jamais pris avec les Français
on sait que l'hypothèse de son départ
est sur la table elle-même a bien
accepté ce terme de fusible la
concernant oui et ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours notamment hier renforce
le sentiment de d'échec en fait
notamment de sa méthode rappelez-vous de
ce qu'on avait dit au lendemain du
second tour des élections législatives
ce qu'avait dit Elisabeth Borg pour
nuancer les mauvais résultats enfin la
déception des législatives c'est que
finalement tout ça n'était pas très
grave puisque on allait innover dans
cette situation inéd sous la Cinquième
République et on dégageant des majorités
de projets et que c'était son rôle à
elle de trouver des gens au centre
gauche au centre droit auprès des LR
évidemment pour pouvoir gouverner faire
passer des réformes importantes c'est un
échec c'est un échec aussi personnel
pour elle évidemment que Emmanuel Macron
est à la manœuvre derrière mais pour
elle aussi c'est normalement le Premier
ministre qui est le chef de la majorité
en tout cas du bloc présidentiel ça n'a
pas fonctionné et pour elle c'est un
vrai désaveu elle ne peut pas être
remplacée tout de suite c'est la
première ministre dans un instant et
même pourquoi pas d'un remaniement qui
était déjà dans les têtes de l'exécutif
avant même le 49 3 mai à ce stade du
débat on sert il permet une
interrogation est-ce que c'est pas la
traduction de notre dépendance de notre
endettement c'est-à-dire que le 49.3
pour moi il a été pris parce que on
prend un risque majeur vis-à-vis des
emprunts il y en a besoin d'une
signature internationale et que on
pouvait pas se permettre de prendre ce
risque elle est intéressante cette
remarque parce que c'est exactement ce
qu'a dit
après au moment de la décision avec ces
ministres le président de la République
dans le huis clos de l'Élysée oui on
entendait on entendait cet argument
depuis un ou deux jours en disant il
faut rassurer les marchés financiers
surtout en ce moment on sait qu'il y a
une banque américaine qui a fait
faillite il y a eu beaucoup de questions
au Gouvernement mardi et effectivement
c'est un argument alors ce qui est assez
drôle risque d'attaque des marchés sur
la dette française exactement ce qui est
assez drôle dans la majorité c'est que
certains disent oui on le savait depuis
le début mais c'est pas très Audi pour
les Français de dire qu'on fait une
réforme des retraites pour assurer les
marchés financiers mais d'autres dans la
majorité nous disent aussi bah si c'est
un argument fallait peut-être le dire un
petit peu plus tôt et dramatiser cet
enjeu parce qu'on a vu que cette réforme
des retraites elle a eu des
justifications tout à fait différentes
depuis le début et c'est vrai ça paraît
un peu le dernier argument l'argument à
quelques heures du vote en fait peu
vendeur de se dire qu'on va travailler
deux ans de plus pour faire plaisir au
marché financier ça c'est grand
politique comme la Grèce plongée dans
l'austérité si on ne fait pas de Ré
pour ce pour complaire alors pas faire
plaisir mais pour complaire au marché
financier ça me paraît vraiment je pense
que ce n'est pas été tenté c'est qu'il
ne devait pas pouvoir marcher on risque
une crise financière bah est-ce qu'on va
pas financière c'est en tout cas
l'argument qui aurait pu être 600
milliards
et la Cour des comptes attiré la
sonnette d'alarme après quoi qu'il en
coûte du covid est-ce que quelqu'un peut
croire que faire travailler deux ans de
plus dans les années qui viennent va
avoir une influence immédiate sur le
taux d'emprunt sur les marchés
financiers franchement c'est pas une
est-ce que c'est un peu revenons
peut-être à l'exécutif pour vous
à ce stage je n'ose même plus utiliser
le mot de crise que j'ai l'impression
que vous ne le reprenez pas je l'assume
mais est-ce que est-ce que vous pensez
que Elisabeth borne peut rester à son
poste est-ce que cette équipe là peut
continuer à gouverner ou ce qu'il est
temps de remanier au fond quel que soit
l'issue des émotion
il sera certainement tant de remanier
l'équipe Elizabeth borne vous savez
attendons lundi soir
s'il n'y a pas de motion de censure qui
réussit si la loi est votée vite
promulguée rendant donc le rip quasi
impossible on peut changer complètement
de perspective et à ce moment-là on dira
bah voilà le gouvernement avec les
moyens dont ils disposait à réussir à
faire passer sa réforme et ensuite
restera la question du rapport de force
avec ce que l'on appelle le mouvement
social est-ce que le mouvement social
tiendra est-ce que le mouvement social
sera unit est-ce que le mouvement social
montra en puissance et quelle sera les
quels seront les réactions de l'opinion
publique
simplement deux secondes pour l'instant
l'opinion publique en effet tient
derrière le mouvement social mais grève
après grève il peut y avoir un effet
de ce soutien et on le sait très bien
là-dessus l'opinion est versatile le
sondeur elle n'est pas
l'opinion est versatile vous avez raison
et elle peut évoluer sans doute pas
basculer il y aura jamais à aucun moment
un mouvement de bascule ou après
les Français vont l'entendre comme au
fond un vote un vrai vote sur la réforme
non parce que il y aura pas de victoire
du gouvernement le gouvernement peut
faire passer son projet mais ce serait
une victoire à la Pyrrhus pour reprendre
un terme un peu éculé mais ce sera ce
sera ça si vous voulez le vrai problème
fondamental de cette réforme à ce moment
bien précis c'est le terme de brutalité
on a reproché au gouvernement et au
président de la République toutes ces
semaines la brutalité brutalité dans le
projet de loi dans son aspect punitif
les Français n'ont pas compris qu'ils
n'ont pas compris c'est pas qu'il
fallait le comprendre mais ils n'ont pas
adhéré à cet argument démographique ou à
l'argument financier que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure de de reporter Las Vegas
on leur vole deux ans de vie enfin deux
ans de belle vie et ça ça peut paraître
basique mais c'est une réalité c'est
premier point et le second point c'est
que le 49-3 n'a fait que renforcer cette
impression de brutalité qui renvoie à
tous les reproches que l'on peut
adresser à Emmanuel Macron quand on
n'est pas un macroniste depuis 5 ans
maintenant alors je voudrais qu'on se
projette un peu sur le fonctionnement de
ce Parlement et de cette Assemblée
nationale pour conclure ce débat on
entend dire que avec ce qui s'est passé
il y a des réformes qui ne pourront plus
mettre être discutées faute de majorité
Elsa alors là il y a un vote qui va
avoir lieu sur le projet de loi
nucléaire ça a priori ça devrait passer
il y a un notek sur les Jeux olympiques
mais c'est vrai que sur des textes
clivant comme celui sur l'immigration
qui était prévu normalement au printemps
fin du printemps début de l'été là
clairement le groupe de la majorité dit
mais on ne peut pas le faire passer ce
texte là il va falloir revoir un petit
peu le fonctionnement et justement
peut-être aussi trouver des textes un
texte sur le travail qui est annoncé
peut-être en septembre est-ce que c'est
pas trop tard est-ce qu'il faut pas
essayer de l'avancer essayer de trouver
des textes un peu plus consensuels
puisque au-delà de la personne
d'Elisabeth Bor c'est évidemment et
fragilisé après cette séquence là
l'interrogation c'est plutôt qu'est-ce
qu'on veut raconter sur la suite du
quinquennat il y a encore quatre ans
donc peut-être que dans la majorité au
gouvernement il y aura des textes
peut-être
que ça va aller à peu près mais
maintenant il nous faut quand même un
objet politique quelque chose qui soit
l'emploi notamment peut-être même des
quatre jours ça demande des
concertations ça demande du temps alors
que certains députés de la majorité ils
aimeraient bien pouvoir dès demain
annoncer voilà des nouvelles un petit
peu plus consensuelles et admises par la
pour négocie avec les syndicats ça reste
compliqué à l'avenir on le on le
comprend libération titrée
sur Macron le début de l'impuissance
est-ce que vous pensez que ce
quinquennat risque de s'arrêter faut de
pouvoir faire voter des réformes parce
que le Président de la République il est
jamais impuissant imaginez que il y est
par exemple la motion de censure que
l'exécutif le scénario habituel sous la
5e répondent par la dissolution que la
majorité n'est plus la majorité il y
aura une cohabitation il y aura une
cohabitation comme François Mitterrand
en a connu une comme Jacques Chirac en a
connu et on a vu à la fois pour Jacques
Chirac
probablement en fonction du rapport de
force on verra parce que la majorité
aura été très efficace pour faire tomber
le gouvernement elle sera inefficace
pour en mettre en place un autre ça faut
pas faut pas rêver il peut pas y avoir
une coalition en effet des extrêmes
extrêmes gauche à l'extrême droite c'est
assez improbable parce mais en revanche
dans le charme discret de l'ombre des
urnes ça ils peuvent être ensemble mais
être ensemble explicitement ça ça
devient beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
difficile donc ça ne sera pas le cas ça
risque d'être extrêmement instable très
compliqué mais le président il gardera
comme François Mitterrand ça avait été
le Cap-François Mitterrand comme ça
avait été le cas de Jacques Chirac il
garde une marge de manœuvre d'autant
plus que face à lui
il aura forcément une majorité mais qui
sera fait de briquet broc comme jamais
on en a connu sous la Cinquième
République ça je peux vous le garantir
on a 5e République et solide on est très
heureux pour Emmanuel Macron de savoir
que il va pas perdre de sa puissance
mais en fait la question c'est non non
ce que vous vous
gardera sa puissance non mais peu
importe c'est ça nourrit le temps est-ce
que pour le pays c'est une bonne idée
est-ce que c'est la situation dans
lequel il nous a mis est une bonne idée
est-ce qu'on se retrouve au-delà à
l'issue de cette séquence
abracadabrantesque est-ce que c'est une
bonne une situation enviable qui nous
propulse vers l'avenir pour mobiliser
tous ceux qui doivent l'être par
transformer je vous donne la parole dans
un instant mais on a parlé de la crise
sociale on a parlé de la crise politique
on verra ce qu'il en est de cette
censurienne crise démocratique aussi et
elle date pas tout 49-3 mais elle vient
l'amplifier il y a des enquêtes qui
montrent que deux tiers des Français
n'ont plus confiance dans nos
institutions là on a une opinion la
majoritairement contre une réforme elle
n'a pas pu être votée dans le pays
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
l'abstention à débouchés politiques à
l'extrême droite ça n'a rien de récent
ça c'est aggraver ça c'est accentué ces
dernières années depuis Emmanuel Macron
est président de la République mais
c'est pas lui qui est responsable du
divorce et de ce de se fausser qui se
creusent de plus en plus entre les
citoyens qui continuent à s'intéresser à
la vie politique et leur classe
politique vous avez raison l'abstention
de cesse de progresser il y a une remise
en question systématique une de la
légitimité de l'élection qui est
dangereuse qui est inquiétante mais sur
ce point ça traduit effectivement la
démocratie représentative aujourd'hui
précédents quinquennat porte une vraie
responsabilité ça pourrait être les
macronistes la prochaine fois s'ils sont
dans l'opposition mais dès qu'un
président est élu on explique que c'est
le président le plus mal élu de la
Cinquième République on explique qu'il a
été élu par défaut on l'a on a dit pour
François Hollande on l'a dit pour
Emmanuel Macron deux fois déjà que
finalement qu'il ne devait pas être
président de la République mais c'est
facile face à Marine Le Pen toutes ces
choses là qui qui remettent qui quelque
part installent une sorte de petite
musique un petit peu perverse je trouve
sur l'île légitimité de l'élu c'est un
vrai problème parce que le périnée en
parler tout à l'heure en guise
d'introduction il y a eu plus d'une
centaine de 49-3 quand vous entendez je
ne défends pas le gouvernement en disant
ça je défends la Constitution on parle
de dévoiement de la démocratie mais
c'est dans la Constitution développement
de la démocratie quand on utilise
justement un certain nombre de d'outils
que nous offre la Constitution c'est la
démocratie mais les Français ne croient
plus dans nos institutions et dans notre
système démocratique il y a une équation
à résoudre extrêmement difficile
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau cette
affaire la crise de confiance elle a
commencé bien avant elle était déjà là
sous Nicolas Sarkozy
un améliore pas les choses je vais pas
vous vous faire une démonstration sur ce
sur ce terrain mais mais en tout cas il
y a une chose qui est claire dans les
semaines qui viennent ça n'est pas la
démocratie de la rue qui peut remplacer
la démocratie représentative la
démocratie représente prévôt c'est bien
clair le mot de la fin oui rapidement
changer c'est l'offre politique qui
était éclatée avant vous aviez la gauche
la droite vous aviez bipolaire vous avez
un système bipolaire vous aviez une
majorité vous aviez des socialistes
alliés à des communistes par exemple
donc vous aviez des alliés et
aujourd'hui il y a une opposition
puissante à gauche une opposition
puissante à l'extrême droite vous êtes
condamné quand vous êtes le quand vous
dirigez le pays vous êtes condamné à
diriger un gouverner avec 30 ou 35% des
voix donc à partir du moment où vous
avez un socle électoral minoritaire et
bien dès qu'il y a une grande réforme
les choses s'avèrent très très
compliquées il y a une réforme des
institutions sur la table on verra ce
que ça donne si elle trouve une majorité
on va s'arrêter là merci évidemment ce
feuilleton des retraites malgré le vote
le passage par le 49.3 va continuer
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre sur elle c'est fait vous restez
avec moi Hugues Pernet dans une dizaine
de minutes nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix vous les voyez ce soir le
requin de Brita sunberg sur la crise des
retraites vue d'Allemagne démocratie
c'est le mot de la semaine de notre
sémiologue Mariette Darrigrand et puis
Bourgoin express avec Marco pommier le
rip quelaco le rip on en parle tout à
l'heure mais d'abord on va plonger je le
disais aux origines de la guerre en
Ukraine avec vous nous sommes en 1990
l'URSS implose et vous débarquez comme
consul général de France à qui elle vous
êtes le premier ambassadeur de France en
Ukraine devenu indépendante 1991 alors
ça valait bien un journal de bord chez
Flammarion pour comprendre et bien
comment le passé fait écho au présent on
voit ça dans l'invitation de Clément
Pergaud et puis on en parle juste après
si on vous invite Hugues Pernet c'est
pour remonter avec vous à la source aux
racines de la guerre entre Ukraine et
Russie fin des années 80 début des
années 90 avec le mur de Berlin un monde
s'effondre un nouveau s'éveille Huc
Pernet vous êtes alors un diplomate
français envoyé dans l'épicentre de ses
secousses
vous êtes nommé conseiller à l'ambassade
de France à Moscou puis ambassadeur de
France à Kiev de 1990 à 1993
c'est ce moment de votre carrière que
vous détaillez dans votre livre un
témoignage pour l'histoire vous racontez
votre arrivée à Kiev en 1990 dans ce qui
est encore la république soviétique du
crâne intégrée à l'URSS vous écrivez la
vie politique locale s'animer et
connaissait des développements
particulièrement importants et riches de
potentiel cela faisait oublier
l'austérité de la vie quotidienne
caractérisée par l'absence de vie
culturelle de distraction cinéma
restaurant de relations amicales
puis l'histoire s'accélère et s'écrit
sous vos yeux
il faut savoir que deux jours après deux
jours après monsieur yelsin menace de
guerre l'Ukraine si elle prend son
indépendance donc si vous voulez ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui c'était déjà écrit
le 26 août 1990 la Russie menace
l'Ukraine si elle devient indépendante
et dit clairement la Crimée est à nous
et le don de basse aussi
un peu plus de 30 ans plus tard la
guerre éclatera alors nous vous posons
la question ce soir Hugues Pernet tout
était-il écrit d'avance ou cette guerre
pouvait-elle être évité
réponse justement toute la question
est-ce que une diplomatie un peu plus
active de la part des Occidentaux
n'aurait pas permis d'éviter ce conflit
qui est vraiment très attristant
pourquoi l'Occident n'a rien vu venir si
tout était là déjà je crois qu'elle a vu
venir je pense qu'elle a pas tout
compris que c'était quand même très
complexe on voyait un pays ce
démembrer sous nos yeux c'était une
puissance nucléaire notre priorité
c'était de s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas
de prolifération nucléaire et toute la
tension était portée là-dessus plus que
sur l'indépendance de l'Ukraine soyons
clair était en Ukraine notamment grande
union soviétique à l'époque et donc si
l'Ukraine était devenu indépendante avec
ses armes nucléaires c'était une
catastrophe et pour comprendre ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui il faut bien
comprendre bien oui comprendre et
analyser ce paramètre nucléaire la
France à l'époque vous en parlez très
bien il y avait une Gorbie Mania
Gorbatchev on revient un petit peu en
arrière parce que vous étiez à Moscou
diplomate à Moscou également
avant l'Ukraine et après et finalement
on comprend que la France regarde avec
énormément de bienveillance l'ouverture
la pérestroïque elle est réformes mais
ne comprend pas du tout qu'il y a le
nationalisme derrière et ce que vous
appelez le démembrement et ça c'est une
sorte de quoi de cécité française je
pense que il y a eu une forme de cécité
je pense que il y avait c'était
tellement extraordinaire de voir le
monde communiste se déliter qu'on n'y
croyait que certains y croyaient et puis
on entretenait le mythe et on ne voulait
pas voir que par en dessous monsieur
Gorbatchev coupe essayer la branche sur
laquelle il était assise la menace des
représailles de Moscou elle a dès le
début dès 1991 je voyais extrêmement ému
en voyant les images vous aviez les
larmes aux yeux à la fois de cette
élection par le monde la proclamation de
l'indépendance qu'est-ce que ça réveille
chez vous le réveil parce que c'était
quand même l'histoire qui se faisait
sous nos yeux c'est les gens je les
connaissais la moitié sont morts déjà
c'était impressionnant c'était
impressionnant et pourtant vous le dites
on l'a vu dans le sujet Boris eltine
mais les Damoclès au-dessus de la dans
le départ c'est que Boris au suffrage
universel donc il est censé être
représenté cette démocratie qui commence
à émerger dans l'ex-URSS et en même
temps il veut reconstituer l'Union
soviétique sous l'égide russes et
l'Ukraine qui était à l'époque la
domination communiste c'était des
conservateurs avec une frange
nationaliste
s'oppose à ça et maintenant on est à
front renverser c'est à dire qu'on a une
Russie qui est conservatrice toujours
expansionniste et une Ukraine qui
devient démocratique et qui essaye de
comporter son indépendance mais on le
voit bien dans l'histoire la Russie
Moscou a toujours considéré l'Ukraine
comme sa propriété très clairement oui
mais c'est pas nécessairement
ressenti par les Ukrainiens comme tel
évidemment mais il faut bien expliquer
que pour les Russes c'était la petite
Russie et et bien avant d'ailleurs les
années 80 la première moitié du XXe
siècle la Russie n'a cessé de piller et
de tuer en Ukraine il y a un
ressentiment massif des Ukrainiens
contre les Russes les Ukrainiens ont
essayé par deux fois de prendre leur
indépendance à chaque fois c'était à
l'occasion de guerre la première fois
c'est à l'issue de la Première Guerre
mondiale les Ukrainiens ont eu un
éphémère indépendance et ils ont négocié
avec l'Empire allemand au traité dans le
premier traité de bercyclaves parce
qu'il y en les deux leur indépendance
cette indépendance a été confortée par
le traité de brésistance qu'avec la
Russie bolchévique mais tout ça a été
annulé par
l'armistice du 11 novembre il a réussi
votre revenu en force en Ukraine en
disant vous avez voulu faire ces
sessions vous allez voir ce que voilà
alors on va parler un peu de vous parce
que c'est aussi un récit incarné de vous
diplomate on est en 1990 le mur est
tombé mais l'Ukraine n'est pas encore
indépendante il y a absolument aucun
Français à Kiev et pourtant la France de
François Mitterrand et de Pierre
Bérégovoy à l'époque décide de créer un
poste de consul général dans la
République socialiste soviétique du
crâne pourquoi justement c'était à
l'époque c'était pour répondre aux
attentes de Monsieur Gorbatchev pour
essayer de voir si on pouvait commercer
c'était justement monsieur Bérégovoy
l'idée c'était de tisser des liens
économiques or quand vous avez pas de
français la seule chose que vous
puissiez faire c'est de la politique
donc c'est expliquer il vous a dit dans
un premier temps vos collègues
diplomates de l'époque les Dominiques de
Villepin les Gérard arrot enterrement
pure première classe faut pas y aller
donc vous avez hésité absolument mais
c'était pas du tout évident c'était
vraiment pas un lieu rêvé pour pour
aller c'était l'Ukraine soviétique il y
avait rien c'était quoi la vie là-bas
c'était très morose mais d'abord il y
avait pas de restaurant il y avait pas
de possibilités de relation amicales il
y avait pas de cinéma je veux dire
c'était travail travail et travail bon
vous acceptez finalement sans regret
vous arrivez vous allez très vite
observer la vie politique et économique
les portes vous sont assez ouvertes mais
en même temps vous êtes extrêmement
surveillés par le KGB mais justement
c'est ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'il y avait une espèce d'Ukraine
soviétique donc avec un KGB qui vous
surveillait il y avait une crème
démocratique qui est
et qui s'ouvrait et qui voulait
justement qui ait des témoins et qui m'a
offert la possibilité d'être un témoin
unique de leur évolution politique et
c'était absolument extraordinaire et un
concevable on a vu une image dans le
sujet du président le premier président
ukrainien élu au suffrage universel
alors kraftchuk qui prononce pas très
bien rendez compte comme c'est méconnu
on connaît même ce nombre
c'était une élection pour autant est-ce
que la démocratie vraiment a pu
s'installer après l'indépendance ou pas
je pense que il y avait une forme de
démocratie on croyait un monde meilleur
mais en fait il n'avait pas du tout
compris ce qui était un système
démocratique pour eux ils ne
comprenaient pas ce qu'on voit
actuellement en France c'est-à-dire le
rôle d'une opposition le rôle d'une
majorité comme on tout ceci progresse
eux ils étaient ils avaient franchi un
pas définitif on était dans le consensus
tout allait bien il depuis partie
communiste donc tout le monde doit être
d'accord pour aller vers le bien et il
ne se rendait pas compte que ils ne
connaissait pas la démocratie d'autre
part ils ne connaissaient pas ils
avaient pas du tout fait les réformes
économiques qui permettaient aux gens de
d'avoir une autonomie financière et
économie que qui leur permettait d'avoir
une liberté de penser vous allez nourrir
en information de gouvernement français
sur la vie politique la vie économique à
l'époque la France avait plutôt intérêt
à garder l'union avec la Russie avec
l'URSS plutôt que de comprendre ce qui
était en train de se jouer c'était pas
son intérêt l'indépendance de l'Ukraine
la France se voyait en puissance
nucléaire et l'Union
soviétique ça représenté un élément d'un
système bipolaire dans laquelle la
France avait un jeu d'intermédiaire
qu'elle pouvait assumer la disparition
de l'URSS réduisait le rôle de la France
d'une part et au contraire accentuer
celui de l'Allemagne
c'est à dire qu'à cette époque on voit
la réunification de l'Allemagne comme
aujourd'hui on va voir le réarmement de
l'Allemagne les
erreurs de jugement par rapport à
l'histoire en acte c'était pas des
erreurs c'était une
une position voilà alors à vous lire la
guerre en Ukraine ne s'arrêtera pas avec
la chute du régime du Kremlin très
clairement vous dites c'est pas
uniquement la guerre de Poutine ce qui
se passe dans le don de basse
aujourd'hui
c'est absolument ce que je veux essayer
d'expliquer parce que je crois que pour
arriver à un système de paix il faut
comprendre l'origine de la guerre cette
guerre comme je le soulignais et c'était
écrit à l'époque c'est pas une
reconstitue pas l'histoire c'est sur la
base de documents écrits de cette époque
je me suis Delphine avait déjà menacé
l'Ukraine de guerre donc monsieur
yelcine monsieur Poutine à l'époque
n'existait pas donc l'après Poutine pour
être encore pire je sais pas s'il serait
pour être encore pire parce il y a quand
même une évolution mais je veux dire il
est pas garanti est-ce que c'est notre
guerre à nous les occidentaux cette
guerre en Ukraine est-ce qu'elle nous
engage nous les démocraties européennes
même si nous n'avons pas de soldats au
sol je pense que nous engage mais pas
nécessairement comme on le voit
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle devrait
nous engager pour rechercher pour
proposer pour promouvoir une solution de
paix parce que je trouve qu'il est
extraordinaire et déprimant de voir
des puissances comme la France comme les
États-Unis ne pas être en mesure de
mettre un terme à une effusion de sang
en Europe bon bah écoutez je renvoie nos
lecteurs Hugues Pernet à ce journal du
premier ambassadeur de France à Kiev aux
origines de la guerre c'est fondamentale
pour comprendre ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui entre entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris de vous
faire réagir on les accueille tout de
suite alors Mariette Dary pour son mot
de la semaine démocratie on en a
beaucoup parlé dans notre premier débat
et Britta senberg du Spiegel le chaos
des retraites vue d'Allemagne on voit ça
dans un instant mais on commence avec
Bourbon Express comme chaque soir
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée nous
est racontée ce soir par Marco pommier
bonsoir Marco bonsoir Myriam mardi je
vous ai parlé d'un acronyme en trois
lettres CMP ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire d'un autre acronyme en trois
lettres RIP référendum d'initiatives
partagés ces larmes brandis par la
gauche pour contrer la réforme des
retraites la gauche qui veut forcer le
gouvernement à consulter les Français
sur ce texte si controversé écoutez
Fabien Roussel
aujourd'hui la suite c'est le rip le
référendum que nous allons déposer
défendre et pendant les 9 mois qui vont
suivre pour obtenir ces 4 millions de
signatures cette réforme devra être
suspendue et donc nous avons encore
l'espoir de l'emporter de faire
respecter le monde du travail et de
créer les conditions que cette réforme
ne soit jamais mise en application en
rendant le pouvoir au peuple
bloquer la réforme c'est bien l'objectif
de Fabien Roussel sauf que selon les
interprétations les choses ne sont pas
aussi simples surtout si la réforme est
promulguée dans les prochains jours par
Emmanuel Macron quoi qu'il en soit cette
proposition de loi référendaire elle a
bien été déposée aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale alors de quoi
s'agit-il précisément le rip et bien ce
rythme Myriam il a vu le jour en 2008
sous la présidence de Nicolas Sarkozy il
s'organise en trois étapes à la première
consiste à réunir un cinquième du
Parlement soit 185 parlementaires là
selon nos informations la proposition de
loi référendaire de la gauche aurait
recueilli 252 signatures d'élus au total
deuxième étape la validation du Conseil
constitutionnel les sages auront un mois
pour valider cette proposition de RIP si
c'est jugé conforme à la Constitution
alors la compte à rebours est lancée
c'est la troisième étape la gauche aura
9 mois et pas un mois de plus pour
réunir un dixième du corps électoral
soit 4,8 millions de Français ça fait
beaucoup précisions de taille une seule
véritable tentative de RIP a eu lieu
jusqu'à aujourd'hui tentative qui a
échoué on écoute Jérôme Guedj
Jérôme Guedj en 2019 le rip sur la
privatisation des aéroports de Paris
avait recueilli un million de soutien là
il vous en faut des signatures 4,8
millions total est-ce que la marche est
pas un peu trop haute mais puisque vous
parlez du Rip sur ADP qu'est-ce qui
s'était passé quand il y a eu un million
de signatures le processus a été
interrompu parce qu'on sentait qu'il y
avait des profondeurs du pays et
pourtant sur un sujet beaucoup plus
étroit que la question de la réforme des
retraites on propose de soumettre à
référendum une question simple est-ce
que de dire que l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite ne peut pas excéder 62 ans
et moi j'espère que le Conseil
constitutionnel à la fois sur les
aspects juridiques notre RIP est rédigé
de manière solide
comprendra que c'est salvateur pour le
fonctionnement démocratique un moment
donné on voit bien la défiance qui
s'installe
voilà vous l'avez compris l'objectif et
bien c'est bien de poursuivre le bras de
fer avec le gouvernement en prenant les
Français à témoin politiquement le
gouvernement aura une épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête c'est ce que nous
confiait ce matin la socialisme Valérie
rabot alors admettons que toutes les
étapes de la procédure soient franchie
il va y avoir un référendum dans cette
hypothèse là dans le pays non non pas
tout de suite Myriam il y aura une toute
dernière étape il faudra que le
Parlement il faudrait que le Parlement
approuve le principe de cette
consultation populaire ça semble peu
probable alors que la droite détient la
majorité au Sénat est très clairement
cette droite sénatoriale elle est pas
vraiment pour la retraite à 62 ans ça
vous aura pas échappé bon et encore
beaucoup de travail l'obstacle
exactement on a hâte de vous entendre
Britta Sandberg journaliste allemand
décor correspondante à Paris du Spiegel
comment nous voici outre-rein les
Allemands est-ce qu'ils nous jugent avec
voilà un peu de critique face aux
poubelles kiflambent et tout d'abord
autant vous dire que vous me rendez pas
la vie facile parce que j'ai passé les
semaines à expliquer pourquoi les
Français ne veulent absolument pas
passer à l'âge de 64 ans pour la
retraite mais ne veulent travailler que
jusqu'à 62 ans et depuis hier il faut
maintenant que j'explique ce que c'est
les 49-3 si c'est vraiment légal que le
président et la première ministre
peuvent
ne pas passer au vote donc c'est pas
facile si les pays va maintenant
s'embraser c'est les questions que alors
les collègues les Allemands se posent la
presse allemande comment elle regarde ce
chaos des retraites elles s'inquiète
elle est très inquiète d'Yvette par
exemple donc c'est un quotidien écrit
aujourd'hui Macron risque une crise de
gouvernement est renforce ainsi le
mouvement de Marine Le Pen je cite il
sortira certainement affaibli de cette
confrontation surtout la mise en place
brutale de cette réforme largement
perçue comme injuste aura les
conséquences sur le climat politique en
France
écrit et parle aujourd'hui sur son site
d'une république française bloquée
il y a des réformes dans un gouvernement
ne se relève jamais la confiance déjà en
baisse dans le président a subi un coup
supplémentaire jeudi Macron renforce
ainsi l'impression qu'il n'est pas
vraiment intéressé par le consensus et
les compromis en Allemagne il est récent
affrontements en France en jusqu'à
présent était considérés avec une
certaine distance mais il est peut-être
temps de s'inquiéter
dites et puis il y a la RD c'est la
première chaîne de la télévision
allemande qui dit maintenant il n'y a
que des perdants le gouvernement a subi
les pires dommages malgré toutes ces
promesses des dialogues et d'unification
de pays il n'a pas réussi à négocier un
compromis viable alors qu'est-ce qui
inquiète le plus les Allemands
je crois qu'à part la violence dans les
rues c'est vraiment l'état de la
démocratie en France qui qui les
préoccupe car la démocratie implique
pour nous et pas seulement pour nous
d'accepter la défaite et d'obtenir
parfois péniblement des compromis et
apparemment le gouvernement français
semble actuellement incapable de faire
les deux c'est la culture allemande qui
nous manque du compromis nous on a quand
même un système qui est basé sur le sur
le parlementarisme depuis la prière donc
depuis des décennies
en plus ce qui paraît incompréhensible
ce que j'ai écrit aujourd'hui dans un
commentaire pour derspiegel c'est
qu'aucune circonstance extérieure ne
poussait Macron à procéder si vite
à faire cette
affaire cette réforme en temps
d'inflation dans cet hiver d'inflation
ayant la guerre en Ukraine en parallèle
le trou de la caisse de retraite n'était
pas si grand qu'il fallait forcément
agir immédiatement
en sort vraiment renforcé et profite le
plus de ce qui s'est passé donc je crois
que la semaine prochaine
peut-être pas toutes mais quelques-unes
hypernet moi je voulais dire simplement
que l'endettement de la France est-elle
que la marge du manœuvre du gouvernement
est très très réduite oui mais ils
auraient pas été obligés de enfin s'ils
avaient négocié maintenant
jean-mars
ils ont été obligés de de pas prendre de
risques
il aurait fallu peut-être réformer un
peu plus tard en général on nous dit où
sont les réformes non non la question
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on la prépare
la réforme comment est-ce qu'on
l'explique quelle est la communication
et et comment est-ce qu'on se met
d'accord aussi avec les partenaires
sociaux donc est-ce qu'une meilleure
préparation n'aurait peut-être pas évité
ce qu'on vit maintenant c'est ça la
question en vraiment faire en faisant
une vraie négociation avec
avec les syndicats et d'autres
partenaires sociaux en tout cas on n'a
pas cette culture ni de sociale ni du
compromis et pourtant la nouvelle donne
politique nous nous l'imposait on va
continuer c'est exactement dans la même
ligne droite avec la démocratie c'est
votre mot de la semaine Mariette cette
démocratie au nom de laquelle et bien à
la fois la colère s'exprime mais aussi
le 49.3 se trouve dans un moment où ce
mot vider pratiquement de son sens c'est
comme un totem c'est une sorte de
signifiance en signifiée on pourrait
dire un totem qu'on brandi un dieu idole
alors que l'on part de toutes les vertus
si je reprends la formule de Laurent
Berger
mais ça veut dire que quand il a dit
c'est un vice de la démocratie la
démocratie donc c'était vraiment donc
quand Hamon on arrive à ce niveau là de
sacralité tout en disant pour les uns
une chose et pour les autres une autre
et on se tape dessus en son nom il faut
venir au sens au sens premier du mot il
faut revenir au le premier du mot alors
là évidemment on est en Grèce tout le
monde le sait
à Athènes mais alors atteint c'est
intéressant parce qu'il la démocratie a
été rêvée elle a été beaucoup plus
théorisée que pratiquée si on veut mais
en tout cas elle avait deux ennemis en
quelque sorte ou deux contraires
l'aristocratie le Cratos des
aristocrates des meilleurs et puis la
ploutocratie ou là c'était le pouvoir de
la richesse donc elle est une sorte de
troisième voie des mots scratos le
pouvoir du peuple alors le pouvoir du
peuple c'est comme ça que l'on dit
aujourd'hui et en particulier les
populistes qu'ils soient d'extrême
gauche ou d'extrême droite ils vont très
vite ils disent c'est le pouvoir du
peuple mais le peuple des mots ça veut
pas dire peuple tout de suite ce qui
veut dire peuple tout de suite en grec
c'est ethnos d'où notre mot ethnie et le
démon est en fait c'est pas un carnet
c'est pas des gens de chair et d'os
comme nous c'est le résultat d'un
système de gouvernance qui est fondé des
Mosses est fondée sur un verbe
d'aimero qui veut dire partager donc en
fait le démos c'est le système par le on
partage les pouvoirs et par extension du
sens c'est les gens qui appliquent ce
système et le font marcher mais c'est
pas tout de suite les gens d'accord et
parfois il faut reconnaître que le
système solaire
certains moments tout système doit
évoluer tout système doit être réparé
quand il le faut et surtout fonctionner
avec des nouveaux outils donc si vous
voulez ce mot cette origine du mot il
nous oblige à renvoyer dos à dos à la
fois les gens qui n'ont pas donné assez
de signes de partage dans la prise de
décision et les gens qui nous disent
trop abruptement c'est le peuple qui
doit gouverner voilà donc là il faut
sortir un peu du franco-français
regardez peut-être un peu en Allemagne
ça c'est toujours très bien mais aussi
en Ukraine mais aussi en Géorgie mais
aussi à Taïwan et là c'est comme si
l'actualité internationale nous redonner
notre nos fondamentaux et c'est eux ces
gens-là démocratie
quand la démocratie est un avenir et
bien à ce moment-là elle redevient à ce
qu'elle était au départ et on voit très
bien qu'elle ne peut pas
s'instrumentaliser mais qu'elle doit
toujours être alliée avec le partage et
l'hybridation ça c'est très important
merci j'ai appris plein de choses sur le
même le mot de démos merci beaucoup
Mariette journal du premier ambassadeur
de France à Kiev malheureusement je n'ai
pas le temps de vous faire réagir mais
on fera ça après l'émission chez
Flammarion merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi c'est le week-end profitez bien et
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]